このマハーカッサパ尊者のエピソードを書いてますけど
まあブッダゴーサラーナっていうのは
このあんまりこの合わない芸に合わないストーリー繋げるんだから
これすごい達人ですけどね
このマハーカッサパ尊者っていうのは
まあすごい隠れたキャラクターで
ブッダお釈迦様が生きてきた時代ではあんまり表に出なかったんです
一応 なんかすっごい全て計画的みたいんですけど
仏教の世界はものすごい微妙に
で サーリプッタ尊者 モクレン尊者がお釈迦様と一緒にビリビリピシピシと活動していて
もう一人偉大なる人物はこのセーフ
セーフにしているんです
セーフというか何といいますか
あの  予備 予備  予備 に しているんです
だから表に出さないんです
それで おそらく まあお年のこととかいろいろ考えていたと思いますけどね
サーリプッタ モクレン両尊者がお釈迦様いる時亡くなったんですね
お釈迦様一人ぼっちになっちゃったんです
お釈迦様も大変だなといった時もありますよ
あの二人がなくて なんか寂しいと
もう寂しいというか まあ見てもなんか絡んで
なんか人がいないような感じがするんだと
お僧侶たちがいるんですけどね
でも人はいつ死ぬかっていうこと
誰にもどうすることもできないし
残りはお釈迦様一人でなんとかなんとかして
お年になっても涅槃に入られて
それでマハーカッサパ尊者が
もう はい これから私の出番やっていうことで出てきたんです
すごい能力なんですね
ものピシッピシと仏教をまとめて整理整頓してしっかりしておいたんです
こんな人にこうではないか
ああではないか そういうことはもう何一つもできない
お釈迦様には色々文句言われたり
色々やって それそんなことはない
すごいもう厳しい YES
かNOかどちらかっていう感じで
やるかやらないかと だからそれぐらい厳密に厳しいんだから
まあお釈迦様いる場合はもう裏にいて
裏でいて 涅槃に入られた途端
これは大変だということでね
亡くなられても知らなかったんですよ
で 突然 ある誰かの連絡で知って
そのままもうああ大変だとすぐ行ったところでもうお釈迦様を荼毘にする準備が全部できていたんですね
荼毘にしようかなと王様
マーラ あそこのね 火を付けても
付けても火が立たないんです
全くもうこの全部この栴檀
木をね 切って あの それ作ったんですけどね
棺は鉄で作ってね 鉄でしたし
それは全部全部決まりありましてね
それ決まり通りにやります
でもあの栴檀っていうのは簡単に火が付きますよ
すごい油ついてる すごい香りもあるしね
でもなかなか火がつかないんです
阿羅漢たちに聞いたら 「
なんででしょうかと これは」と
言ったらもう「ちょっと待ってください」と 「
責任者が来てないんだ」と
仏教の次の で カッサパ尊者がもう歩いてまず来て
でお釈迦様の見ることはできなかったし
もう中に入れているしね
まあだからまた外へ出すということもできないしね
一応足があるところに三回回って礼をしたと
テキストではね それで足が外に出ましたと書いてますけどね
というか まあ足が見えるようになったということですね
それはまあいろいろ現象作れますからね
で 三回拝んで後ろに下がったら
パッと日が自動的に 日が昇ったんです
だからそこはすごい なんで明確に記録しているかというと
次の責任者っていうことなんです
で ブッダは責任者を認定しないんです
仏教には責任者はいません
最高権力者っていうのはいません
そうしちゃうと民主主義がなくなっちゃうんです
ブッダだけに ブッダが亡くなったら法が教えが最高責任者なんです
個人ではありません まあしかし人間やることだからね
まあ仮に誰か先輩がいた方がいいぐらいで
そこはもう民主主義 儀式儀式より守られてます
で そういうカッサパ尊者なんですけど
だからカッサパ尊者に対してエピソードっていうのはものすごいたくさんあるし
経典もたくさんあるし
サンユッタニカーセクションにトッサカッサパ尊者の名前でもいろいろお経典もたくさんあるし
こちらにあるのはあまり経典なんかにない
もうあまり出てこない
でもあった出来事みたいんですけど
カッサパ尊者がこのあまり社会に出ませんだから托鉢しなくちゃご飯食べられないでしょうに
托鉢しに行くんですね
托鉢に行く場合でも 極端に貧困なカーストも低くて仕事もなくて
もう浮浪者というかホームレスというかね
乞食ですね 乞食の人々がいるところに行くんです
托鉢に そういう人々は
おそらく比丘たちを見たことがないかもしれませんし
ブッダ見るどころか だからそこら辺にカッサパ尊者托鉢にしたってもニュースにはなりません
斎場とかそこら辺に行っちゃうと
もう相方だからもう有名ですよ
誰も顔を見てないだけ
どなたでしょうかと もうほとんど体形もお釈迦様に似ていたんだそうです
そのすごい人を誰かと誰も見ていないんです
見たことはないというぐらい
たまたまお釈迦様のところにアラーハンたちが集まるとか
たまたま来る 大会議がある時だけ
それは出てくる お釈迦様頼んだこともありますよ
もうどんどん年も取っていくでしょう
だからまあちょっと街で一緒にいたらどうでしょうかと
断って帰ったんです だからこのすごい乞食のね
ところに托鉢に出ていて
これ決まってね だからもう本当にろくなものを召し上がってないんですよ
それなのにこの帝釈天やら神々やら
もうずっとそこら辺でカッサパ尊者らところでウロウロしている
全然相手にしないんだと
で この帝釈天 帝釈 天国の神々が
まあ天女たちがね やっぱり徳を我々も徳を積まなくちゃいけないんだと
天国にいたってもね これはどうしようもないと
だからお布施でもしようかなと思ったら
誰にお布施しようかなと
やっぱりカッサパ尊者のことしか頭に出てこないんですよ
お布施するんだったらカッサパ尊者にお布施するんだよと
ブッダのところには近寄れないし
もうなかなか日にちはないしね
お釈迦様はほとんど歩いてるんだから
その日その日そういうところで托鉢に出ちゃうし
カッサパ尊者は裏舞台で自由にいるんですからね
活動に参加しないんだから
で カッサパ尊者に托鉢をね
食事をね すごい素晴らしい食事をね
天国の人々を作るもんだからね
用意して托鉢に出るまで待っていたんだそうです
待っていたら だから決まりはね
順番で托鉢に行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
カッサパ尊者だとすごいえらい連中が入るんですね
信じられないごちそう用意してあって
この決まりあまり気にしないんです
君たち何だと それは我々はこういうもので
どうかお布施を受け取ってくださいと
出て行けと それだけ 出て行けと
まあ神々でもそんなこと言えないでしょうね
もう家一軒一軒托鉢に行くのは決まりでしょうと言ったら負けますけどね
カッサパ尊者でも お釈迦様でもちゃんと論理的に言えば
はい 負けたということで清くと言えますよ
女性の出家はそういうことだ
女性は出家はダメダメダメですよと
もうもうこんな生活できませんと
迷惑だと すごいもう迷惑だというと
大概もうやっぱりやめたいという感じでみんな控えるでしょうね
でもそれでアナンダ尊者とプラジャパティゴータミーお互いに話あってね
アナンダ尊者にしてみれば
プラジャパティゴータミーっていうのは偉い方でしょうに
お母さんの過去でしょうに
だからもう女性のパワーで抑えちゃったのアナンダ尊者を
アナンダ尊者はその気になる
やっぱり偉大なる母親でしょうに
出家させてあげた方がいいんじゃないかなと
プラジャパティゴータミーぐらいは別にいいかもしれませんだけど
それからなんだ問題作ったのみんな
その時もアナンダ尊者
お釈迦様も断っているんです
もうダメという また二度と言えないでしょうね
ブッダに対しては アナンダ尊者はこの場合は論理で倒すしかないんだと
お釈迦様いかがでしょうかと
もし女性が出家して真剣真面目に修行するならば
悟れないんでしょうかね
女性だからと 何故ならそんなことないです
誰でも修行したら悟れますよと
では女は出家してはいけないということは
悟る並みいる人々に言語道断さすことになるんじゃないかなと
それで論理的にはお釈迦様負けちゃったんです
で 何のこともんわかりました
八項目ありますよ それ守るんだったら認めますよと
八項目何よと それでアナンダ尊者に聞いてもらって
一発で覚えられますからね
ゴータミー妃のところに行って
ブッダがこういう八項目を唱えましたと
八項目守るならば認めますというお言葉ですよと
ゴータミーさんはすごく喜んで八項目守りますと
と発言したんですね それはアナンダ尊者また行って
ブッダに お母様がね ちゃんと何の文句もなく喜んで八項目守ると発表しましたと
と言ったら あ しまったと言って
しまった なぜならもうどうしようもないんですよ
だからそれで出家なんですね
何のしきたりも何もなく
ブッダの決まりだから
しまったと もうはっきりおっしゃったんだからね
大変なことになったと
あとでいっぱい尼さんたちが出家塔でプレジャクティゴートムからかわれちゃったんですよ
あなたは正式的にブッダの戒律をテキストに合わせたい通りに出家してないんだと
だからあなたはちょっとおかしいと
ゴートミ氏もやっぱり本当そうなんですね
自分が勝手に具足してたんだからね
で どうしようかといったら
お釈迦様に相談したら
いいえ 彼女は私の言葉によって八項目守りますというあの言葉で
彼女は正真正銘の出家になったと
その瞬間から だからお釈迦様は言うことをしましたと言ってます
お釈迦様はね どうすることもできない
それ取り消しとかね だから論理で言えば良かったのにね
この神々もそうじゃなくて
我々は 我々の幸福のために嘘をついたと
出て行けと言ってもしょうがないこと
出て行くしかないんです
私はこの貧困のどん底の人々のところに産んだよと
向こうもなかなか出て行きたくなかったんですよ
怒ったではなくて あなた方はね
何だと思ってるんだよ
自分のことをと 指をなら出て行けと言うと
その神々はみんなもうそれいらないんですよ
これではいらかんでしょうし
出て行ったんですね それで帝釈天がカッサパ尊者を騙したんですね
で 騙すた話がありましてね
それで神々の天女たちから話を聞いて
帝釈天がそういうことかというところで
自分がもうものすごい貧しい村
村ではない これはブロックですからね
そちらの中で一番貧しく
一番貧困に見えるように
ちっちゃなちょっと屋根ちょこっと作って
一人もやっと寝られるぐらいの
もう貧乏な乞食の中で見たって
ものすごいかわいそうで
もうなんて不幸な人やと思う姿に
なって 自分のもう一人奥様二人いますけどね
一人はあしゅらから奪った人でね
かなり気に入りなんです
その二人で で カッサパ尊者がやっぱり順番で一番貧しいところから始まるっていうことで
そちらに行ったら ボロボロもう立てられない
動かないぐらいのおじさんが
なんとか鉢を持って家の中にいて
で 普通は何かご飯一粒ぐらい
ひとさじぐらいは鉢に入れるんですけど
鉢を貸してくださいって言ったら貸してあげるんです
で 中にもう色々 色々声出しながら
もうボロボロだからね
やっと中に入って食事を入れて
渡したんですね いっぱい一段全部入ってるんですね
これおかしいんですね
それいくらなんで 開けてみれば
この香りがサーッと その全部その地方に広げていったんですね
それがすごく怒ったんですけど
もうどうしようもないんです
受け取ったんだからね
ものすごく怒鳴って お前泥棒やと
貧しい人の功徳を盗んだと
でも大作戦は一応やっぱり政治家っていうのは
もうもうそういう人騙しばっかしやってますからね
たとえ紙の政治家であろうと変わりはないんです
でお前泥棒やと もう怒鳴ってもう怒ったんですけど
すごく大作戦がもう喜んじゃって
お布施するならばカッサパ尊者に布施するんだよ
それで大作戦がすごく喜んで
ある偈を アホーダーナン・パラマダーナン・カッサペー・スパッティタン・スパティッティタンということをもうすごく喜んで
これ言いながらもうやったぞという日本語で言えばね
私はやったと だからそれはパーリ語でもう素晴らしいお布施
カッサパ尊者に差し上げることっていうのは大変
なんて素晴らしい幸せかなということを
で これ神の言葉だからね
これは阿羅漢たちやら魔物やら
まあそこを聞いてね で
それで話はなんであれほどあの人は喜んでいるんでしょうかというと
まあそれはまあこういう出来事であると
だから人に顔を合わせないで
すごいボロ服を衣を着て
貧しい人々の貧しいご飯だけ召し上がって
もうすごい森の中で洞窟にいるんですよ
それは森の中に入って
洞窟の中 洞窟があって
ピッタリというその中に入っているんです
村には来ない それでも有名な人は有名だと
人間知らなくても もう天国まで生きて行き渡るんだと
そのカッサパ尊者の徳は
カッサパ尊者の特色っていうのは
他の坊さんよりもすごい戒律を厳しく守ったっていうことなんです
これを厳しく守る羽目になったんで
お釈迦様の衣を着ちゃったんだからね
お釈迦様が悟り開いてから
このある奴隷の人 女性が死んじゃって
その金持ちの家は まあこの遺体をね
まあ布で巻いて捨てちゃったんです
お釈迦様は修行行中でステータスったって終わっただけでね
そんなろくな衣もなかったでしょうし
一応ブッダになってからはすごい品格よくしっかりしなくちゃいけないということもあるし
だから衣と作らなくちゃということで
服を探しに行って この遺体を見つけて
で 遺体を捨てちゃって
腐っていたんですけどね
遺体は その時は だから
召使いの人だからね そんな高価な絹の布で巻くということはなくて
麻ですよ 麻で それを取って
それを手で洗って で 衣を作ったんですね
一人で それを着ていたんですね
だからそれでカッサパ尊者出家するんだということでね
もう勝手に カッサパ尊者とかお坊様を見てね
二人ともすごい偉大なのお二方でしたけどね
で お互い別れてくると
お釈迦様がもう一応計画通りに偉い偉大な人々はちゃんと弟子とにかく取っちゃうんですね
その能力はブッダにしかないんですけどね
で 待ち構えていたんだよ
お釈迦様は カッサパ尊者が来るところを
自分が出家したんですけど
まだ誰の教えも知らないし
仏法を見て話を聞いて
それで悟り開いて より深い悟りを開いて
で それからもう二人すごく仲良く
ある時期は一緒にいたんですよ
仲良く そこでまあ お釈迦様と一緒にいて
まあ座りたがって 他で言ったら
さあ カッサパ尊者が自分の衣を畳んで
こちらに座ってくださいと
お釈迦様はカッサパ尊者が着ていた衣の上に座ったんですね
座ったらちょっと手でこれ触ってみて
これはすっごい立派な服
もう自分大金持ちでしたからね
家から一番高価なもう布で衣作って出て行ったんで
財産は捨てましたけどね
この一着だけは上等な生地で
布で 6万長者でしたけどね
それだけなんで家から持ってきたの
あ これ結構柔らかいねと言ったんです
で その場でもう差し上げるしかないんですね
だからサーカさんそれ着てくださいと
で 自分の衣を脱いであげたんですから
おそらく上半身が何も着てなかったでしょうね
その時は ではあんたは？私はこれ着ますよと
あの朝出てきた それは一言
あなたに着られるのかと
できますと その決まりなんですよ
で 頑張っていますということなんです
ブッダの衣を着て見ろと
だから誰よりも完璧に戒律を守るんです
それから一度も信者さんからもうすくって
まだ衣なんか来なかったんです
全部自分で拾って 脱いで
そういうすごいボロ服なんです
そうなると だからブッダのこの一言葉に合わせた生き方なんですね
それでまあ能力はありましたしね
それから現代仏教っていうのはカッサパ尊者の仏教なんです
どちらにしたって 結局は
で 解釈はしなかったんですけど
カッサパ尊者は全部整理整頓してくれたんですね
要点をね まあそういうエピソードは書いてますけど
まあ一応カッサパ尊者がこの
かなり天国まで人気者でいたっていうことだけ言いたがってるんです
まあ一回 二回ぐらいは
お釈迦様が大会議やるんで
だったんです この偉大なる阿羅漢たち
みんな一か所に集めて
お釈迦様集めて なかなか一か所に集まらないんですね
八十人の方々がみんな
で その場合は当然カッサパ尊者も来なくちゃいけないんです
コンラジ長老やらね 第一番目の弟子とかね
集めたところで当然神々は来る
神々ならまあ梵天の神々も降りてきたんですけどね
大概皆さん見てみようかなと
聖者たちを その時でも大釈尊が下りてきて
カッサパ尊者探すんですね
どこどこです どこですかとかね
だから他のカッサパ尊者はまだ来てないんでしょうかとかね
だから何よこの人は もうカッサパ尊者まだかよまだかと
それでもうどうせ遅くなりますからね
カッサパ尊者どうせ遅くなるんです
お葬式の場合でもえらい遅くなりましたし
この大会議の時でもかなり遅くなったんで
で来た いらっしゃったんですね
それでそちらに飛んで行って
もう一生懸命足を触ったりして礼をする
なんかカッサパ尊者だけに礼をするためになんかもう来たようなもう雰囲気なんですね
これっておかしいでしょと
お坊さんたちも文句言ったら
お釈迦様がやっぱりそういうことですと
偉大なる道徳を守っている人がね
その道徳っていうのはすごいエネルギーで
それは天にまで届くんですよ
だから不幸になるくはないんです
お守りなんかつけなくても
ちゃんと戒律を守っているんだったら
それっていうのはものすごい強烈なお守りなんです
何の不幸にもなりませんし
何のあれ 何て言いますか
呪いも入りません どんな呪文をかけても
どんな呪いかけられても
何のこともないんです
すっごいお守りになります
だからあの戒律と定義する場合は
ブッダ教ではほとんど言語学をなんとか無視して定義したりするんだからね
この守るというね 巨大な守りという意味でシーラというんだよと
定義もしています はい
遅くなりましたので この辺で話を終了いたします